Alrighty then.
Let's see what happens.
So for this stream today,
what I wanna try and show off is
Telegraf's
metric buffer.
So let's start with a little bit of
background, I guess. Telegraf
is a
metrics collector
that works with pretty much any time series
databases and
a few other non time series databases.
So it has the ability through plugins
to go and collect some sort of metrics,
perform aggregations or filtering on those metrics, and
then output them somewhere.
So let's start off then with a really
simple Telegraf configuration,
collecting some really simple metrics, and just writing
them to our console.
It's probably the easiest way to get started.
So
first, we need to generate a Telegraf configuration
file.
We can do that through a Telegraf config,
and I put that to a file.
Now we're gonna strip this right back to
the
complete
bare essentials.
So we're not even gonna have any global
tags.
We're gonna keep a few of the agent
configuration settings.
So right now, we're gonna have a collection
interval of ten seconds. That means for all
of the plug ins that I have configured,
reach out every ten seconds and grab the
new metric.
The round interval just means that it keeps
your numbers, like,
zero seconds past the minute, ten seconds past
the minute, twenty seconds past the minute, regardless
of when you start Telegraf.
There are reasons for doing that, mostly around
grouping and windowing when you query the data.
For now, we don't really care about that.
Now we are gonna play with the metric
buffer and batch size,
but first, we just wanna get Telegraf running,
so we're gonna keep them commented out.
And then I'm gonna jump down
to here.
And just because we're gonna get a feel
for Telegraf, I'm gonna leave debug setting
untrue.
Next, I'm gonna emit the host name
just because it's not important for the purposes
of this, but that's what allow you say
you're running Telegraf on every machine in your
infrastructure,
then a tag value would be added to
every metric with the host name the metric
was collected from.
A, this scenario is a single machine, and
b, I'll probably run out of a Docker
container, so the hosting isn't gonna give me
any value anyway.
Now I'm going to delete
everything else in this file.
It's quite large
because we have over 200
plug ins at the moment. So there are,
like, a 70 input plugins. There are 70
output plugins
plus all the processors, aggregators, etcetera.
So that's why there are everything in the
file that we generate is an example of
every plugin. So we're gonna start without that.
Now we need to collect some input first
before we can output it anywhere. So for
this, I'm gonna use the main plugin.
So I just pulled up the docs for
this for the GitHub repository.
Telegraf,
you go into the plugins directory.
We're gonna look at the inputs, and then
I've got the main.
The reason I'm using the the reason I'm
using this plugin is that there's no configuration.
We just enable it, and it does
it gives us some information about the memory
usage on our machine, and the output form
is relatively trivial as well. Let's see. Single
measurement with a bunch of fields.
Now we wanna be able to output that
somewhere.
So
I'm gonna output this to file,
and we're just gonna use standard out,
and we're gonna save this.
So in theory,
I run Telegraf config,
Telegraf.conf.
Every ten seconds, it should reach out, find
out what the memory consumption is on my
machine, and then output output that to standard
out.
And, of course, we have to wait ten
seconds, so, you know, start the awkward silence.
No.
So
we'll just quit that. Now what's important about
this?
So
for the uninitiated,
this is line protocol.
So at the start, we have the measurement
name,
which is MEM,
and then we have all of our values.
There could be tags here,
but it just appears that we don't have
any. That's okay.
But we have a lot of information about
the data we're collecting on the memory. And
then at the end, we have a nanosecond
resolution time stamp for when this metric was
collected.
We can see here
that we have two metrics being written very,
very quickly and eighty six microseconds,
and our buffer was flushed, and then I
killed it.
Nice and simple.
So now we
wanna be able to
store them somewhere.
And to do that, I'm going to just
bring on some Docker containers.
I always use version 2.4
because I don't like version three. It's focused
on cloud deployments and Kubernetes and Docker Swarm,
and you lose out some cool functionality. I'll
have another rant about that another day.
But for the time being, I'm gonna jump
over to another repository,
which is my influx DB examples.
And I'm actually just gonna copy
the setup.
That was the worst example to pick.
Let's try
yeah. This won't get quite a lot of
it.
So I'm just going to run and flex
DB one.
And we will actually run Telegraf here too.
So we will copy this even though we
don't need most of it.
And we'll just call this Telegraf. We're just
gonna use the official image.
We don't need any ports, and the only
thing we need to mount on is our
Telegraf configuration,
which is just Telegraf.com.
So now we should have InfluxDB running within
this Docker Compose network under InfluxDB.
InfluxDB runs on port eight zero eight six,
so
we just have to configure
Telegraf to write to that. Now, again, we
already have this configured
here.
So I'm just gonna copy and paste this.
The reason I'm using influx to be one
is there's no authentication, and it just saves
me five minutes faffing around with that.
So we're gonna write to influx to be
on the service name on the port.
Now we also wanna be able to visualize
these metrics. I could do that that through
the influx CLI, but we want something a
bit nicer. So I'm also gonna copy in
our Chrome graph configuration,
which is our UI.
Back over here.
Chronograph,
point it to influx DB, and we can
acknowledge passer.
We are gonna expose this port so that
we can actually browse to it. And this
is just one of the reason I like
the two point x syntax for Docker Compose
is we can actually have conditional based objects.
So
let's spend all of that up. We'll do
it in the background.
Most of the images won't take too long
to pull.
Anytime
you like.
Make sure they're comfy.
Alright. Let's see. All three services are up
and running.
Telegraf should be still right to standard out,
so we can do docker compose logs dash
f.
Follow it.
Yep. Good. All working well. And if we
scroll up here,
we can also see that we have output.
Bus creation failed. You can ignore that generally.
It happens again later, and we have no
errors when flushing the right metrics. So InfluxDB
should be receiving them. So we're saving these
metrics as well as the standard out.
So what we'll do is we'll browse
to Chronograph
and click on explore.
We'll delete all that. We've got our memory
measurement here.
We'll do it like that.
Okay. Cool.
There are no tags, so I can't filter
any further, but let's take a look at
our available
let's do the percentage stuff. So
used
and now we can see that our used
percentage of memory is 30, and we have
63% available of memory. So we're now claim
collecting metrics.
Now in order for me to explain
the metric buffer stuff,
we're gonna have to get some internal metrics
as well. So we're gonna enable
the internal plug in for Telegraf,
and if we just pull up the documentation
for that,
you can see the internal plug in collects
metrics with Telegraf agent itself, yada yada yada.
And we're gonna collect the memory stats. Not
important,
but, you know, configure and Telegraf plug out
is relatively easy
just like that. So now we need to
restart our Telegraf instance, and what we should
see here
is a new
measurement.
So let's do docker pause, restart Telegraf,
and that's just to bring in that new
configuration file. I could have exacted into the
container and done a reload, but the restart
is just as effective.
To make sure everything is still working, we're
gonna turn the logs once more. What we
should see at the
top, yep, as our internal input is now
enabled, and we're still writing batches of metrics.
So where we were writing two metrics before,
we're now writing seven metrics, and that's just
those internal ones we're doing. So if we
jump back over to our UI, give it
a quick refresh,
and then we have all of the internal
metrics for Telegraf.
The ones that I am particularly curious about
are going to be
that this is group by output. We have
two outputs, so there should be standard out
and fail fail
standard out slash influx DB. And we can
take a look at the metrics dropped, metrics
written.
So what have we got here?
We have our metrics written to fail, 21,
metrics written to mFlexDB 14,
metrics dropped, mFlexDB zero, metrics dropped, file zero.
So we're not dropping any metrics to either
output,
but we are writing metrics
to both of our outputs.
Good.
So what is the metric buffer?
So the metric buffer is a concept in
Telegraf that means if any of your inputs
are down for any period of time and
Telegraf is unable to write those metrics to
that output is that it will store them
in memory,
and it will store them in memory for
as much as you allow with the metric
buffer limit.
So based on what we've seen from the
console out standard out stuff, we were writing
seven metrics every ten seconds.
So
let's say
that we are going to shut down InfluxDB
for
thirty seconds, if I can find something to
talk about for that long.
Then we're gonna need a metric buffer of
at least seven times three because of three
intervals, which is 21.
But we actually wanna see some draw metrics
as well. So let's just say that we
do
15 pair output, and that's always important to
remember the comments here. This metric buffer is
pair output. And for whatever reason, you were
writing to five different databases,
and you had a very large metric buffer,
say, thousand or a hundred thousand, then that
would be a multiple of how many outputs
you have, which would mean you're actually storing
for 50,000 metrics. But for the metric buffer
50,005
outputs, that would be 250,000
metrics held in memory. And depending on the
size and shape of those metrics,
that could be quite a lot of RAM.
Look. Let's just mark the bar in mind.
So now we need to restart Telegraf again
over a new metric buffer limit, and we
shouldn't see any metrics being dropped still because
nothing is broken. Nothing is done.
Perfect. So let's just tell the logs, wait
till we see the flash, and then jump
back over to our chronograph.
Awesome.
So let's just
turn on auto refresh here.
Let's say every ten seconds just because that's
what our interval is. Although, I guess, we're
we're gonna do the
I'm gonna force it to drop metrics. I
mean, speed that up. So we'll we'll just
let's put it on five for now.
One,
two, three.
Okay.
So you can see we're still writing to
both of our outputs. This is gonna gradually
go up. Of course, our refreshes will slightly
faster. Well, twice as fast as our interval,
so the growth here is gonna be linear,
but almost.
And our metrics dropped as at zero. So
we're still not dropping any metrics, which is
fantastic. In fact, I should just match them
up so that we don't get those false
rerates anyway.
We'll do let's really jump over here.
And we'll actually just set this to five
seconds so we can speed this up a
little bit, and then we're not looking for
me as entertainment,
which means we'll double our buffer limit just
so that I can shut down our FoxDB
and then force the drop metrics, but not
too quickly that I can't talk about what's
actually going on as well. So let's restart
again.
We'll toggle logs. We'll wait for output.
I mean, I just had a thought. You
know, I haven't really tested the stream, so
I know the video is being captured. I'm
assuming people can hear me.
I guess we'll think that soon enough.
So let's jump back down to five seconds
here. We just do a manual refresh to
force it.
Hopefully,
see some metrics.
There we go.
And 21 metrics run to InfluxDB, and you
can see this number is resetting every time
we restart Telegraf because it's essentially a new
version of Telegraf, all the stat reset.
Remember at 36, 30 five, so forth, so
forth, so forth. So that's all good. Now
what happens
if I now this is gonna be difficult
to see. I probably should have run two
influx d b's side by side so that
I can show you them at the same
time. But what we're gonna do is stop
influx d b,
which means that Chronograph is no longer gonna
be able to fetch any metrics,
but that's okay.
So we wanna trigger the metric buffer
to go over. So let's just take a
look at logs, and we can follow this
along here.
But we can already see the buffer fullness
is 30 of 30 metrics.
We're unable to write to influx DB.
Now we were at the point where all
of our metrics that are being written our
our oldest metrics that are being written to
influx DB are now being lost,
that we pushed
out of the way in favor of the
more recent metrics.
At least I think that's how it works.
I should really know that.
Oh,
I do that every time.
So now that m plus d b should
almost be healthy again, we should start to
see all of the metrics we were in
to both standard out and m plus d
b again.
Yeah. Our buffer
looks good. Let's see one more.
Yeah. I think we're good. So we jump
back over here. Awesome.
So now we can see we have three
lanes, and that's because our metrics being dropped
was actually on the rise.
And in fact, if we add
a buffer size to this,
you can see that our buffer hits are
in here
and then drops back down as influx DB
comes back on,
and then everything goes back to normal.
So the metric buffer is a really simple
setting within Telegraf.
It just gives you that kinda extra resiliency
in case your influx DB
or your, you know, any other time series
database you're using goes down for any period
of time.
And so the larger you make the mesh
buffer, the more memory you're gonna consume. In
fact,
it's probably not worth showing it
just because we were only caching a very
small amount.
And if we take a look at the
available percent
and use
percent,
I don't think it's gonna make a blip.
Yeah. Barely.
So let's go drop. Nope. My thoughts are
dropped. Edit written
buffer.
Yeah. So the metric buffer just means that
we can catch all of those metrics and
memory in the event that we lose, like,
say that the network problem or database goes
down, anything that could happen within our infrastructure,
then Telegraf will capture them, hold on to
them, and then we try as often as
possible until it can write them back out
to your database of choice.
So it's a very powerful setting,
and it takes, like, three seconds to configure.
All you have to do is a little
bit of a little bit of math,
you know, understand how many metrics you're writing
per second. So, you know, you can just
take a look
at this here, and we can see that,
you know, we've got this linear in the
growth. We wanna work out what that is
every second or every minute depending on how
often you've got your interval configured.
And then, say, I wanna be able to
handle resiliency for up to fifteen minutes, maybe
even an hour or maybe six hours, whatever
your failure scenario that you're comfortable with is.
Multiply that by the number of outputs, and
then use that as your metric buffer limit.
And that'll give you resiliency
with all of your metric collections, and hopefully,
you never lose any more data again.
So this is just a short stream. I'm
just testing this out. I hope you found
it somewhat valuable.
If you watched, please let me know. Let
me know if starting from scratch like this
was useful. If you draw slightly more larger
examples or preview it first. I'll be happy
to try that out as well. But thank
you very much, and I will speak to
you all later.